el desembarco más grande de la historia
el 6 de junio de 1944 quedó marcado en
la historia como una jornada considerada
vital para lograr la liberación de
Francia y del frente occidental del
control de la Alemania nazi la
denominada operación overlock que debía
ejecutarse el 5 de junio y fue pospuesta
un día por el mal clima supuso la
estocada final para una debilitada
fuerzas del eje en el desembarco de
normandía participaron hasta 7000 barcos
de distintos calados 156.000 soldados Y
10.000 vehículos tropas de Estados
Unidos Reino Unido y Canadá se
dirigieron a cinco puntos de la costa
Norte francesa con nombres claves los
estadounidenses se dirigieron hacia las
playas de Yuta y Omaha los británicos
hacia las de gol y sworth y las
canadienses a juno la compleja misión
también involucró a 23.000 paracaidistas
quienes traspasaron las líneas enemigas
y formaron cordones de apoyo para el
desembarco anfibio a pesar del éxito de
la operación el coste es de Vidas para
el bloque de los aliados fue alto
solamente terminado el día mil
cuatrocientos soldados aliados murieron
y otros 9000 fueron heridos o quedaron
desaparecidos en tanto que Las bajas
alemanas oscilaron entre los 4.000 y los
9000 hombres en la playa Worth la marea
impidió el avance de vehículos Y si bien
pudieran afirmarse tierra adentro no
completaron el objetivo de tomar la
estratégica ciudad de caen Omaha el
sitio de combates más feroces conllevó
un gran número de Muertos
estadounidenses tras no poder romper las
defensas alemanas el día de fue el
inicio de una nueva Ronda de
enfrentamiento a centraliados y alemanes
en Europa la cual se llevó entre
callejones de pueblos y ciudad de
francesas pero que terminó con la
liberación de París a finales de agosto
de 1944 y que dejó aproximadamente
200.000 muertos en el proceso